freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
tag einen wunderbaren tag denn ich habe
mir etwas neues überlegt und ich werde
den gesamten tag lang nur essen gehen
das ist schon mal sehr gut und ich werde
nur die teuersten sachen auf den karten
bestellen natürlich im sinne der
wissenschaft ich will herausfinden sind
die teuersten sachen auf den karten
wirklich die besten und müssen natürlich
erst mal frühstücken gehen deshalb ist
auf dem weg zu einem geheizten frühstück
sport hier in köln und es gab also ich
dachte mir zum frühstück können wir uns
mal ein bisschen was mir drüben louis de
braak beziehungsweise saint-louis der
breakfast company irgendwas war da mit
dem namen auf jeden fall ein sehr
beliebter raten in köln und ich bin mir
sicher das ist ja auch ein bisschen was
gehoben das haben für uns
nur essen gehen und immer nur das
teuerste von der stelle
dann würde ich sagen nämlich noch einmal
die experte dick nordic style und dazu
einen eisglatter einfach ich hätte
gedacht dass es teurer ist hier weil es
ja voll die gehypte location aber 13 70
ist schon knackig also wenn ich normal
frühstücken gehen würde ich mir
vielleicht nicht unbedingt was zu 30 70
bestellen aber es ist so was von dem
rahmen alter für geile experte das wird
auch sehr sehr lecker wie kann ich nicht
gelesen wie die sind doch nordic sei
irgendwie mit
den un
so wird schon kommen wird lecker disco
[Musik]
so das essen ist da wir haben hier
wirklich unmengen an lachs das ist
wirklich sehr großzügig muss man sagen
ich würde diese menge an lachs ist der
preis auch wirklich gerecht werden ich
kann nicht direkt sagen also hier ist
nichts abzocke kein nichts und wenn ihr
einfach mal guckt dass wir in der mitte
das passierte guck mal wie das wackelt
ist einfach wackelpudding not habe noch
nichts gegessen heute und ich freue mich
so sehr darauf jetzt vom erstmal der
klassische eier an schnitt bereit
so alles auf einmal eigelb und
nächsten halt immer in saint-louis wird
braucht aber ehrlich find das so fair
dem preis ist eine packung lachs drauf
alter dazu noch vor dieser salat für was
frischesten üben heute wird ein guter
tag
mächtige vom beat frischknecht wir
gehören da ist jede menge für pakistan
geröstetes brot kommt er will jetzt mein
du kannst ja auch heute richtig das
können wir uns der zweite stopp wird ein
hochpreisiges burger restaurant und ich
kann mir nur vorstellen was mich da
erwartet also gesund ist auf jeden fall
was anderes so ich habe ein bisschen zu
hause gestellt bisschen verdaut und ich
habe gerade was wichtiges gesagt und
zwar dass ich bestimmt wieder etwas
ungesundes essen werde ihr habt es
bestimmt schon gedacht auf meinem
channel das passiert häufiger also sein
sollte und da gibt es eine sache die
wirklich wichtig ist und deshalb möchte
ich euch meinen partner hat lady greens
vorstellen wir gehen wir gemeinsam ein
nämlich nicht vernünftig und ordentlich
vitamine zuzuführen nicht nur vitamine
sondern auch jede menge andere sachen
die hier drin sind und warum ich das
benutze und warum ich davon überzeugt
bin erzähle ich euch jetzt erst mal
warum ich davon überzeugt bin und das
ist wirklich keine floskel sondern ich
habe mich davon überzeugt ich wollte
bevor wir hier irgendwas machen schickt
mir erst mal was zu ich probiere das
ganze und ich muss euch sagen ich hab
das getrunken und ich war so gut und
nach einer halben stunde ungelogen habe
ich mich besser gefühlt und dann habe
ich mich ein bisschen schlau gemacht
warum das so ist es ja die greens
enthält 75 vitamine mineralstoffe
präbiotika und adapter gene und jede
menge andere gute sachen und das krasse
ist man macht sich einen es lediglich
spring und habe mit einem löffel alle
täglichen nährstoff bedürfnisse und das
beste ist dass es nicht für irgendeine
sportler ernährung zugeschnitten oder
sonstwas nein auch wenn man den ganzen
tag rum fairen restaurants testet kann
man das super gut integrieren ihr könnt
euch natürlich jetzt sehen wir können
uns viel erzählen aber es gibt eine 60
tage geld-zurück-garantie
und nicht nur das wenn ihr über meinen
classic dreams dot com / max dietrich
kohler link übrigens bestellt kriegt ihr
dazu eine jahresdosis vitamin d3 und
fünf travel pack 2 logischerweise haben
wir die schale die man im startup
wegbekommt nicht überall mit hinnehmen
deshalb tut etwas gutes ich von mir was
gut ist das ganze ab alle infos noch
eine infobox und weiter geht's mit
wir sind jetzt auf der aachener straße
und davon ist auch schon unser laden
ernst gespannt wie teuer star wird wurde
ist der richtig geladen
herbert biesenberger doppelbürger 28
euro aber der laden dazu das wäre für
das video so geil gewesen bin ich wieder
aufmachen dabei bestand sogar dass die
offenheit überlegen uns was anderes und
am besten überlegen man schnell was
anderes habe ernst hunger
[Musik]
herbert café de paris ich war selbst
noch nie dort weiß das ist glaube ich
auch preis sie werden kann deshalb weiß
ich nicht ob sie beste entscheidung ist
hier hin zu gehen aber wir machen nachts
leute also ich weiß auf jeden fall aus
meiner in story dass da nur die schönen
und reichen hingehen da sind wir richtig
ich überfliege mal dass auch für ausland
1850 jung hast du es dir haben das wie
heißt das parallele rinderfilet 250
gramm vom lavastein
52 ein angemessenes mittagessen würde
ich sagen das können wir uns jetzt
nehmen wir mit oder grüner spargel
pfifferlinge doch halb schnitzel mit
kartoffelsalat oder sogar jetzt fördert
aber ich muss halt was
gucken wir mal
horst riege erstmal sie werden nicht so
gut sein wie bei hänssler letztens
glaube ich nicht
okay war schon mal drei konnten die
werden eh nicht so gut sein und dann war
diese puffer sind ganz andere mit schale
dran uns aber trotzdem sicher sehr
lecker aber erinnert euch letzte woche
kann ich gesagt aber mal sehen
menschenrecht wo sind sie sehen wir hier
zu vertiefen kitchen club kann ich
probiere jetzt das eigentlich wichtige
machtmittel schnitt gerne machen bitte
schön aber man merkt uns noch schön wir
haben nichts gesagt also sollte es ja
mit medium
ja schön schlag auf jeden fall länger
auf der unterseite probieren schnitt
vier fällen auch einfachen 1 ist man
auch viel zu selten tiffany
das schmeckt er schmiss kommt direkt
über es kein generelles preisniveau
bisschen höher weil auch von innen laden
das szenario schließlich auch
persönliche top boxen noch mal an sorgen
dass er gewillt ich würde einfach so von
mir selbst aus würde ich mir eigentlich
nicht bestellen aber man kann es auf
jeden fall machen wenn man sich
[Musik]
bitte helft mir gibts was tolleres
zweitteuerste bin super gerne hier das
ist mit einer meiner lieblings hätten zu
den ich aber sehr selten schaffe zudem
anlass kommen wir noch mal vorbei findet
ihr mega ist aber wie in italien sofort
und wenn es jetzt noch etwas gibt warum
kann trüffel passt sich das teuerste
sein beides 23 50 23 erstmal deutlich
angenehmer für mein geldbeutel ist heute
mittag polyp allegri hier wahrscheinlich
oder kleiner voll porno er die
putenschnitzel verlinken pfifferlinge
hat sich heute schon mal so lieb ist
nicht meine erste wahl ich würde
wirklich wirklich gerne gerade
bestellen
damit hätten wir auch schon mal die
frage beantwortet ist das teuer ist
immer das beste thunfisch habe diese tun
habe ich noch genug vom von henzler das
heißt dass wirklich sehr politisch aber
ist auch geil ich meine durch so sachen
wenn man sich so die challenges steht
dann probiert man auch noch mal neue
sachen auf gesagt hätte ich würde das
nicht bestellen aber ich habe zum
letzten mal bevor
deshalb
[Musik]
so hören wir unseren tellern sehr sehr
hübsch muss ich sagen wirklich man hat
das auf dem teller man denkt man ist
nicht in der kölner innenstadt sondern
man ist in italien und dann ist
eigentlich alles richtig bei einem guten
italiener das frische zitrone drauf
wichtig und da bin ich gespannt ob wir
vielleicht doch schmeckt wo also richtig
ordentlich drüber jetzt sehen wir mal
fast schon ein bisschen was komisch
seit wann ist voll cool so cremig dicker
das ist ein gar nicht so dieses harte
weißt du ja hat das eigentlich dann blöd
ja ja kann es sein dass wir immer noch
schlecht gegessen hast wenn ich jetzt ja
sagen meine mama das video seht dann
aber wirklich richtig gut ich bin
wirklich positiv überrascht ich war ein
bisschen traurig dass ich keine pasta
herzen konnte leider nicht das erste war
aber richtig frisch ist leichtes essen
drin so frittierter rosmarin thymian
erste bibel sky also nur kulinarisch so
von der komplexität auf jeden fall der
höhepunkt von heute aber ich muss noch
ein bisschen wirken lassen und dann wird
auch dieser traumhaften tag zu einigen
knusprig herzlich belohnt als frühchen
und mein fazit nicht immer das duo
bedacht nehmen wir lust haben aber wenn
ich mal was neues ausprobieren wollt
auch wenn es das teuerste ist häufig
eine gute idee also mit einem espresso
dass mir das ganze jetzt nochmal
ausklingen ich muss sagen das war schon
sehr sehr gut heute haben also preis
nicht vollkommen in ordnung und richtig
lecker also ich sags mal mit meinen
lieblingsessen heute auf jeden fall
insgesamt war es aber ein sehr lockerer
tag und ich sage euch ehrlich ich bin
gespannt wie das ist wenn wir das ganze
mit dem günstigsten hessen von der karte
machen weil ich glaube sondern die
restaurants gut sind passt das auch
danke sehr jetzt habe ich sagen leute
die uns zur nächsten video wieder macht
es gut bestellt nicht immer das teuerste
aber manchmal kann man es nicht
geschafft